the idea of substitution substitution
another word you could put it for it
he's swapping I like swapping can I
don't think of any other synonyms words
we use in everyday language that would
mean substitute or swap surely you can
think of all yes switch excellent
okay another one for me trade yes very
good trade one thing for another kid
change a focused on exchange the reason
why is you can use it to say change one
thing for another
but it's not quite the same as these are
wool will sort of expand on what the
difference is in a minute but yeah
exchange exchange that's a bit ok and
what more can you want to give another
one oh is that the one I give you
another one one more replace okay so I'm
lucky to have all of these words then
what's it called in between all of these
and why is exchange just a tiny bit
different but better then change what is
it that makes the one two three four
five yes that is the preface but what
does that change about the me yeah
you're using the plates that are on the
list now we have exchanges in our in our
shopping centers don't we for instance
the reason why exchange is better than
change right is and we were struggling
to come with any other words one weren't
you
it's literally I'll give you one thing
and you sort of get the same thing back
but maybe in a slightly different form
for instance you might swap US dollars
for Australian dollars right but I would
assume you know if you give them some
map you're expecting pretty much a
similar back it wouldn't be an exchange
if you didn't get the same amount
whereas change is kind of like I give
you five dollars and then you give me
you know some product and change is
actually quite a lot different yeah
because that's the young that is the
abbreviation for US dollars and this is
the abbreviation for that's really not
okay so what does this have to do with
algebra well if you remember algebra
right it was all bad for the particular
key ideas pronumerals in other words
they're letters that we put in place of
numbers I guess you could say they're
letters that have been substituted for
numbers okay so for instance if I said
something like this
hey is actually a number it's it's
really a number I just don't know what
it is at the moment right I've
substituted whatever that unknown number
is for this letter Amy okay but I can
just as easily go back the other way
okay so for instance I can say and I'd
like you to write this down just to love
it straight where a equals three so now
you see this number that I didn't know
before right I'm assigning it a value or
what maybe I found out through some
earlier part of the question I found out
that that's what the value of a is now I
can substitute this into this okay so I
can say when N equals two five eight
minus four is equal to well let's see
what happens when I put three back
instead of a right I'll say five times
three because that's what 5a is short
for right five times 8 minus 4 and this
is the kind of question you were doing
wasn't it right in fact this may this
itself may have been one opinion
remember all right now what's that equal
to well that's 5 times 3 which is 15
minus 4 which is 11 excellent okay so
you can see this thing here this
expression
it's very important this is an
expression it's not an equation right
there's no equal sign there okay I can
take a certain value of a and substitute
it into the expression okay in fact
that's so important I'm going to UM
label that on the side of the usual to
write this this process here is
substituting a value into an expression
you'll hear that phrase a lot right
can you see you've got some important
pieces there right what's the value it's
this that's the value there right
it's the pronumeral but now I'm saying
well what if the protocol was this now
what I'm putting it into is the
expression right value into the
expression these are kind of like your
two pieces in a puzzle they interlock
okay and that process is substitute an
important thing you get is this
expression it can equal different things
if we substitute different things in
there okay so for example suppose a
wasn't three let's suppose it was let's
do something fun let's do some negatives
because we had some of those before
what is negative 2 I'm gonna do the same
process here right everywhere I see a
I'm going to substitute it for negative
2 ok let's do that I'll have 5 times
negative 2
I put the brackets in there just to
clarify that that's a negative and not a
minus sign right - 4 ok 5 times negative
2 that's 5 times they do - we're just
regular 5 times 2 is 10 so 5 times
negative 2 would be negative excellent
negative 10 there you go that's that
part there - 4 ok so if you have picture
your number line right now you've tense
all the way over here on the left of 0
and then you gotta be further so what
are you get you
- negative I should say negative 14
good so you can see this is one
expression 5a - a cool right
it takes a lot of different values when
I substance you different values in this
process is super super important